hi morgan hey this movie is so beautiful
from the animation to the songs the
lessons about loss and love
why was it so important for you to be
part of this movie
um i think there's two answers to that
the primary one is audrey wells
uh i've worked with her numerous times
and
i think it was it was so important for
me to be a part of her
um the last project because she passed
away during this project
and it was important to me to be a part
of her last last one
i did her first film yeah um so to be
able to do her last film and then also
the entire story of it you know it being
about
you know a girl you know who is just
trying to find
her way in her heart and she decides to
build a rocket
you know what i mean we've now
and i'm so happy to see this in in
numerous animated films
that the idea of what it is to be a girl
um is changing you know one of the ways
that you're gonna figure out how to
solve your problems
is not relying on i don't know some
boy it's like you're gonna you're gonna
rely on yourself
and your and your little weird friends
you know
i love that um you know starting out in
this industry in your business what
would you say was
your reaching for the moon moment
something that you really wanted that
you made happen
oh that's a very good question
what was the thing that you know that's
a really good question but it's really
really hard to say
in four minutes no but in one thing or
another
i know i wanted to reach people yeah do
you know how
to reach people that's all i know i knew
i wanted to do i wanted to connect to
people
you know being a performer it's like
this deep um
it's almost like sense of purpose or or
whatever you're in this
you you're able to feel a a fundamental
kind of energy which is
a connection um but i and i did not
realize that it would
most actually be in in probably
television because
you know my my relationship with
television has
reached the widest audience possible so
yeah
that's a great answer um you know i'm
such a huge fan of
killing eve is there any updates on
season four has everything just been
pushed back
right now everything has just been
pushed back you know we don't know
what's going to happen in the world you
know everyone is
is is in the place of the unknown and
uh we don't want to forego what killing
eve is i mean we can't
fall in a studio in london and make it
look like
lisbon you know you know i want to go to
lisbon
i want to go to lisbon you know we're
going to
wherever all the settings are because
it's such a a part of the dna of the
show
so we'll just have to wait and see what
opens up
yeah well i'm sure you have been asked
this a number of times but
if and when grey's anatomy does decide
to end would you be interested in
returning as christina one last time for
the series finale
i gotta tell you i wish i had a dollar
for a number of times and i'm gonna say
i'm sorry
it's it's like it's like i'm happy to
answer it and
and i'm i'm hoping that people
at one i'm i'm extremely grateful that
you're
asking me that question because it's if
if that means that people are still
invested and interested in christina
young a character that
was who who i left six years ago then
i'm really grateful for it
um and um there are so many new projects
and
i mean i'm a different person so i'm not
the same
yeah awesome it was so great talking to
you such a huge fan
just love your work thank you
you